hi everyone my name is sai venom and I'm
with the IBM cloud team today let's talk
about blockchain I'm excited to talk
about this because I feel like there's a
lot of misconceptions out there about
the technology and in addition there's a
lot of concepts that can be difficult to
grasp in this video I want to dive into
the fundamentals of blockchain we'll
start with the definition blockchain is
a distributed and immutable ledger
allowing you to track almost anything
tangible or intangible goods most of us
are probably familiar with crypto
currencies or blockchain is used to
track transactions so to better
understand how block chains are
distributed let's start with an analogy
let's say I'm with a group of friends
and I lend my friend Pat $10 now the
friends see the transaction go down and
they know that I have the correct amount
of money and in addition they've
essentially endorsed the transaction and
they made a record of it now next week
when Pat comes back to me to ask how
much money I had initially lent her we
could easily go to any one of my friends
that have a record of that transaction
now block chains are distributed as all
of the nodes that are running in that
blockchain network have a record of
every transaction that's ever taken
place now that's kind of lends itself to
the distributed nature of blockchain
so although ledger technology has been
around for some times even simple
Ledger's blockchain takes advantage of
it by having a single source of truth
and has a distributed nature where
everyone has the same copy of that
blockchain next let's introduce the fact
that blockchain is immutable to do so
let's dive into the pieces that make up
a blockchain so in a block we have three
major pieces first we're gonna have the
transactions so these are going to be
all the transactions that occurred when
that block was created in addition
there's going to be a hash a hash is
essentially a digital fingerprint so it
represents the transactions that are in
the block and it's completely unique so
if any of the transactions were to be
changed the hash would also change so
let's pick a couple of letters for the
hash
really it's an alphanumeric sequence
that's usually a lot longer more secure
it's also gonna have the hash of the
previous block in the chain so let's say
we're you know right in the middle of a
blockchain here and we'll pick something
for the the previous hash say maybe to a
and so now let's move on to the next
block next block is gonna have its own
set of transactions as well as the
previous hash which corresponds to this
one right here as well as its own hash
and so on and so forth we can kind of
extrapolate all of the hashes in
previous Ashes so you can imagine that
if you were to want to tamper with any
of the transactions that have occurred
or change it so for example to change
one of the transactions this one the
hash would change and because of that
the previous hash of the next block in
the chain would now be incorrect so to
fix that you would have to tamper with
every single block in the chain and that
would immediately become apparent so in
this sense block chains are immutable
and very tamper resistant now the next
thing I want to talk about is the idea
of a permissioned versus a
permissionless block chain so we'll
start with and permissionless block
chain
now when most of us think of block
chains were probably thinking of crypto
currencies which are public and
permissionless now that means anyone can
see all the transactions that have ever
taken place now identities are not
exactly revealed it's only the addresses
that people have but regardless all the
transactions are public and in addition
anyone can register themselves to be one
of the nodes in the network essentially
having a copy of the blockchain and any
time it gets updated and new
transactions are made they would get a
new block so you have to imagine it's
quite a problem for all of these nodes
to have a copy of that blockchain when
new transactions come in how do they
reach a consensus on which transactions
will make up the next block that's done
so using a consensus algorithm let's
break down how this works for a
permissionless public blockchain
so a client will first submit a
transaction that transaction will join a
list of other transactions that have
been made on the network and then the
next thing that will happen the note is
going to start picking up those
transactions and it'll validate by
looking through all of the transactions
that have happened in the blockchain so
far that those are also valid it'll kind
of emulate a block and then start
something called a proof-of-work
algorithm now this is a consensus
algorithm that public permissionless
block chains use and essentially this is
how they're able to reach a consensus on
which block should be next essentially
it's gonna be a very complex algorithm
cryptographic hash puzzle that all of
the nodes are working together to solve
as soon as one of the nodes solves it
they've essentially unlocked the
position of the next block and what
they'll do is they'll broadcast that
position of that next block to all of
the other nodes in the network as well
as adding it into their own blockchain
so a proof-of-work algorithm is actually
quite consuming on the processing and
the electricity and a global scale so
although it's kind of required for
supporting public permissionless block
chains where anyone can be a node and
anyone can submit transactions or submit
their hardware to kind of enable the
adding of new blocks you you don't want
to take advantage of those kind of
algorithms when you're working with
blockchain for business and this would
be something like a permissioned
blockchain so in a permissioned
blockchain so this would be something
like hyper ledger fabric.you you have
the idea of pluggable consensus
algorithms now you don't want to do
something like proof of work because
solving those complex algorithms just to
find the next block it's not necessary
when the nodes within a blockchain
network are trusted so that's one of the
first concepts here so pluggable
consensus
now the nodes in a permissioned
blockchain are trusted so they generally
know each other in addition they don't
always just represent users but entire
organizations so in this case it's
actually very important that privacy is
one of the main kind of tenants of a
permissioned blockchain let's take an
example let's say that there's a
retailer that purchases a hundred pounds
of produce at $1,000
so we'll say it's a buy order for a
hundred pounds at $1,000 now the
manufacturer receives the order from the
retailer and says ok let's approve it
let's make sure we have enough in the
warehouse and let's work with the
shipping company so they go to the
shipping company and they say ok let's
ship this hundred pounds and it's gonna
cost them a hundred dollars to actually
make that shipment now there's there's
some privacy concerns here the
manufacturer has to have all the
information that's fine they need to
know about the buy order that was placed
as well as the shipment order that
they've placed but the retailer although
they need to know information about the
buy order as well as the amount as well
as the kind of the price of it they
don't necessarily need to know how much
it costs to ship it but they might want
to know when it was shipped and how much
it was worth on the same hand for the
shipper they need to know that they
place a shipment order the amount and
the cost of it and they need to know
maybe when the order was placed but they
don't necessarily need to know how much
the retailer spent now the same goes for
perhaps more retailers that the
manufacturer might be working with
now if manufacturer is offering a
different price for the product for one
retailer rather than the other one it
doesn't make sense for the retailer's to
know about the competing prices so in
this case although all of the
organizations are part of the block
chain only the retailer's that are part
of the transactions that took place
should be able to see that information
so in this case in blockchain for
business it's actually pretty important
that privacy is part of
a and being able to control who can see
particular transactional information the
last thing I want to touch on here is
the fact that in permission blockchains
you can really make transactions more
efficient I think one of the most
successful applications of blockchain
technology is something called Smart
contracts essentially this is code
that's running on the blockchain and
whenever certain conditions are met
they're automatically executed so in
this particular example whenever that
retailer made that purchase order to the
manufacturer for this amount of goods
there's probably a manufacturing agent
that double checks that the order has
all the necessary information in it
they then probably go with the shipping
agency to make sure they can cover the
shipment and that the warehouse has the
correct amount of goods they'll then
make a shipment order now imagine if we
could automate that whole process that's
what you can do with smart contracts
essentially code that will make sure
that all the necessary information is
met the warehouse has a correct amount
of goods and then it'll automatically
create the shipment record if any one of
those conditions is not met they could
automatically release a refund to the
buyer this greatly speeds up the process
of the contract for everyone involved
the retailer the shipper as well as the
manufacturer thanks for joining me for
this quick overview of blockchain
technology we've really only scratched
the surface so if you want to see more
videos like this be sure to subscribe if
you like the video drop a like and if
you have any questions be sure to drop a
comment below thank you